*Song*
You didn't see me, (we did)
You Didn't See Me (we did)
but here I am!
Peewwwdiepie
Cardboard cutouts
are definitely
still funny,
Oh
OK
kay?
And while I'm at it,
I'm definitely not...
running out of... original Ideas.
Tell 'em, Danny!
Danny Devito : He's Out of ideas Again
PewDiePie : Danny, for fuck's, sake
we practiced this
Okay?
I'm not- I'm not running out of ideas.
Danny,
you're the new Danny, now.
That's right.
Tell 'em.
Danny Devito 2 : BITCH, I'M DANNY, NOW SUCK IT
PewDiePie : *pulls a dead meme*
I've been doing this for a while that I'm running out of ideas,
and uhh....
*processing query*
The thing...that I uhh...
That I've been doing this I, uh....
I tend to take jokes
*computing*
and uh...
just keep going with them
n' kinda...
go too far
and then
umm...
*thinking.*
*thinking..*
and then of...
and then a bit later ...
people start asking "Wait, is... is he a Nazi"?
*laughs as though he's saying: "as if"*
Come on,
I upload videos
every single day.
Alright?
it's not like six years of doing YouTube
has made me run run dry of Ideas. That's
not what's happening here
BUZZFEED
BuzzFeed is Running Out of Ideas!
I've -
I've got plenty - I've got catalogs and sacks of ideas
"What's Your Inner Potato?" Has BuzzFeed
done that one?
*clap*
*sassy* I don't think so
...wait
They have... What is this, "The Simpsons?"
"15 Things With Hedgehogs That Look Like Hedgehogs"
Are you kidding me?
*Sarcastic Applause*
How is this possible!?
Okay, well
alright we're gonna have to think
a little harder here okay uh... because I'm
not out of ideas and let me prove this
once and for all
"You Might Be Cleaning Your Penis Wrong"
*flicks the air with tongue like a lizard*
goddamn it,
goddamn it
How?
"So in case you didn't know you should be cleaning
your penis pretty much every day..."
*realization*
Do you clean it every day?
I think it's time that we finally acknowledge that gifs...
... are now a hate symbol. Good job BuzzFeed,
you did it, because every time I see
these I want to die
I really really just
want to make better videos
I know no one's going to believe me when I say that,
but I am trying
okay
but yeah I can come up with ideas but I want to do
stuff that I haven't done before I want
to do something different and I want it
at the same time make other people but
like the old stuff happy in it it says
it's a joke it's a joke it's hard but
I think it's possible in them trying to
try to handle it the best way I can
but in the end if it seems like I'm not coming up with ideas
I just want to try out different stuff
I made a Facebook post saying that I am hiring and a lot
of people took it the wrong way and and
thought that I was sort of like
replacing myself and taking a step back or
something like that I have no intention
of doing that whatsoever
I don't mean to keep talking about the whole media thing
but the last piece of the puzzle sort of
that didn't really come out in the media
was rebel mode uh... which was the company
that I was working on and that got shut
down and it's something that I've been
working on for three or four years and
it really sucked I think that's probably
the worst thing with this whole thing
going down I think it's rebel mode but
it wasn't really mentioned in the media
I guess it's not as important because I
never talked about revenue because rebel mode
never really got to where to a point
where I was really happy with it so I
didn't until then I kind of wanted to
keep it in the back but literally the
last three or four years I've been doing
YouTube and trying to run this business
that you know doesn't exist anymore
yeah
it sucks but I think
it doesn't in the long run it won't
really matter but at the same time my
point with all this is that now I'm
hiring because I want to do more stuff
and if that's never going to replace
what I'm doing between us and this
channel it's basically this channel is
running at its maximum capacity right I
don't have videos ready in advance this
shit is running daily okay and it's a
lot of challenges but with doing daily
content it's stupid I really shouldn't
be doing it I really really should just
fucking go back and upload twice a week
or some shit and then take a step back
but I feel really really love that daily
challenge the daily grind of just being
like hey, I'm going to make a video
today no matter what and sometimes it
really works and sometimes it doesn't
that doesn't mean I'm Running Out of Ideas
goddamn it
but basically now that
revenue is gone there's a gap for me to
do other things there's a whole opening
thing part of me really just wanted to
feed more into the youtube channel i
think that's a better idea for me to
spend my time with also please don't
apply to the job because we have way too
many applicants and thats just, so please
don't stay away I don't need you
so yeah
long story short I'm not Out of Ideas uh...
I got one right now
"Leonardo DiCaprio Might Be a Human Puppy"
that's a good idea
god fucking dammit
dammit BuzzFeed
I'm sick of your shit how the fuck do you
make this many articles so yeah please
don't take what I say too seriously I feel
like I feel like honestly I need one of
those South Park things in front of the
videos now where it's like don't take
anything I say take seriously whether
you're a fan or not it's not a good idea
I mean it is for you not for me so just
don't just don't do it I guess a lot of
people speculating like actual list that
i'm going to step down or some shit like
that especially I noticed that with the
Facebook post I'm not believe it or not
behind this fucking character I'm I'm
more tightly than ever to be making
videos and I'm
I'm really really excited about it and I
don't want you to get the wrong idea so
sorry I make too many jokes sometimes I
realized that's the problem now for sure
and I'll try and try my best to make
things more clear in the future I don't
know I don't know how to get past this
to be honest but all I can say for now
is there's a lot of exciting stuff
coming at already working on some new
projects and I can't wait to share them
with you and until then I hope my videos
will suffice something that I realized
especially these last couple of weeks is
how incredibly lucky I am to be here to
be making these videos how lucky I am to
every single day do what I love it's
something that I'm so incredibly
grateful for and no matter what I that
that just means everything to me and I
know that wouldn't be possible without
you guys watching me so thank you for
watching and I hope I can do even better
I'm trying I am do you wanna
*kisses fist, licks fist*
do you wanna...
*countinues to sensually lick/kiss fist*
(Felix....no...)
... do this brofist? It's a wet one